you will be told your whole life that
you need to learn to listen I would say
that you need to learn to be the last to
speak I see it in boardrooms every day
of the week even people who consider
themselves good leaders who may actually
be decent leaders will walk into a room
and say here's the problem here's what I
think but I'm interested in your opinion
let's go around the room it's too late
the skill to hold your opinions to
yourself until everyone has spoken does
two things
one it gives everybody else the feeling
that they have been heard it give me
gives everyone else the ability to feel
that they have contributed and two you
get the benefit of hearing what
everybody else has to think before you
render your opinion the skill is really
to keep your opinions to yourself if you
agree with somebody don't nod yes if you
disagree with somebody don't nod no
simply sit there take it all in and the
only thing you're allowed to do is ask
questions so that you can understand
what they mean and why they have the
opinion that they have you must
understand from where they are speaking
why they have the opinion they have not
just what they are saying and at the end
you will get your turn
it sounds easy it's not practice being
the last to speak read decision we make
in our lives it's our way of saying
something about who we are and what we
believe this is why authenticity matters
this is why you have to say and do the
things you actually believe because the
things you say and do are symbols of who
you are and we look for those symbols so
we can find people who believe what we
believe so if you're putting out false
symbols you will attract people to those
symbols it companies that are crystal
clear in what they believe they're
consistent of what they do and
everything they say and everything they
do serves as a symbol of the set of
values and beliefs we use those symbols
to say something about who we are we
surround ourselves with the people and
the products and the brands that say
something about who we are and when we
confine the people who believe what we
believe were weirdly drawn to them and
so the more you can give of yourself the
more you can give
what you believe the more you can
discipline with discipline saying boo
and do the things you actually believe
strange things start to happen you just
watched two amazing clips from Simon
sonic take the next three minutes to sit
quietly and think about how you can
apply them to your business and your
life believe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]